Como
afinar las semanas que estaban en el
posibilidad de que por fin me este aqui
como tener a Marlon en la red eléctrica en
final de la lengua no el creador paralizado
pudo así ofrecer una
fueron minutos de energia lia ya le falta
de combustible aquí porque dijo que
el dolor de las plantas electricas del pais
centralidad que mismo olvidan que el
fe que es por un mes estuvo bien
capaz de ofrecer pero voy a llorar de
luz a lia
actual sobre todo si lo ves en la parte
de la montaña y eso depende de la República
para
comiendo cables y hospitales dependiendo de ello
mercado en cargadores privados
sigue trabajando allí de lo contrario
perfil que muy pocos tu
puede permitir la penetración de la oración
la energía de hecho el poder gustó menos que
que en toda tu locura que nosotros
son superiores al valor actual de
cosas del minimo legal y para tu abuela
no podía aferrarse a los días o donde el
su día va para el líbano todos
asume que su fantasía es combustible
podría causar episodios similares
durante el próximo invierno